[Music]
matthew is on the line in san diego
california he's a new listener i'm told
matthew you're on the ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my phone call
yeah you bet how can we help sir
um yeah so i'm i'm new uh basically i
went on the internet and googled uh
financial um coaches and the ramsey show
popped up
nice i don't yeah yeah we like the
google we like showing up on the google
don't we george it's it's hard to do and
we did it and i'm glad we well now you
are here matthew why were you looking
for that
well so um i was listening to a podcast
and you guys did a couple segments and i
really really loved it um and i kept
listening to it and then one little five
segment popped up about uh crypto fraud
and um unfortunately in the past couple
weeks i am a victim of crypto fraud
yeah i got scammed um
all in all about 35 000. oh my goodness
is that money you had
no it's it's a loans that i took out oh
boy
gosh yeah and uh i i thought it was
legit because i originally invested 500
and that grew and i was able to extract
that into my bank account
and so that's when i thought it was real
so they had big promises about returns
on your investment and they proved it
with a little investment to then get you
baited into more is that what happened
exactly
exactly exactly what happened oh boy
so now you're in a 35 000 hole on this
do you have any other debt
yeah so we uh took out um a personal
loan at the beginning of the year of
twenty five thousand dollars uh to
consolidate uh my wife and i uh
loans were recently married we got
married last year
we were supposed to get married in 2020
but copen and we had to push it back
a couple years
because we wanted more than five people
to be there
so we pushed it back and then uh we got
married uh consolidated all of our loans
and now we are expecting a kid uh next
month our first baby next month oh
congratulations
thank you so yeah so we got a 25 000
personal loan that we took out and then
we have both of our
student loans
uh and then we have her her car
loan all right so
i'm assuming that you called for us to
help you start up come up with a plan to
dig out of this correct
exactly yeah so i was looking through
your website um and there's just there's
a lot of information on there a lot of
books and i was just wondering what
would be the first step for somebody
like me to to start in in this program i
love it well the first step is to not go
into any more debt we've got to stop the
bleeding and make sure that we've got
our four walls covered so that's your
food utilities housing transportation do
you have all those bills covered you can
make ends meet
yes okay the next thing we want to do is
get on a tight budget we've got a free
app called every dollar that you can
download and list out your income minus
your expenses we want that to equal zero
meaning you've assigned every single
dollar a job what is your income
household um my my income i'm salary at
at a hundred thousand dollars and then
my wife is hourly she brings home maybe
about uh
fifty thousand so we're about 150. okay
great and what's the total amount of
consumer debt you guys have
uh probably a little over
um a hundred thousand okay
so what we're going to do is lay them
out smallest to largest and i don't want
you doing any more consolidation loans
because that's not fixing any any
problems here we're just moving around
the debt and feeling like we did
something
okay and so i want you to separate all
the debts put them in a spreadsheet
whatever you need to do list them out on
paper smallest to largest and ignore the
interest rate don't even write the
interest rate down and i want you to
make minimum payments on all of those
debts except for the smallest one what
is your smallest debt
uh smallest debt would probably be the
five thousand dollar loan
is that the car
no that that is one of the loans that i
took out to give
to invest to give to the scammers
because they wanted five thousand
dollars to open up um a channel directly
to me oh boy okay well and who's that
loan through
it's through um
um
it's through through my uh bank i don't
know if i i can say
i'm trying to figure this out the bank
gave you a loan what are the days what
did you say the loan was for
it was for a personal loan
oh okay and then they go whatever you do
with that money is your business
exactly all right so we're going to
knock out that 5 000 debt as fast as we
can how quickly could you do that do you
guys have any money in savings
yes yes we do we we have um we have a
stock account that has pretty pretty
good amount of money in there
okay let's go ahead and cash that out
now you go look at the tax implications
talk with your tax advisor but we're
gonna just get out of any non-retirement
accounts to scratch up as much cash as
we can to attack this debt how much do
you have in stock
uh right now we got a little over ten
thousand
okay all right so yeah i would cash that
out the tax burden won't be big on that
and you'll knock out that first debt
today
okay and once you feel that progress
we're gonna keep going down the list
until we knock out all of the debts
using that debt snowball method that i
just walked you through
and if that means cashing out till you
just have a thousand dollars in savings
for a while i'm okay with that because
right now this is
your hair should be on fire at this debt
and so that might mean you're getting a
side job to bring your income up to 150
so that you're not trying to plow
through this for the next few years
yeah i i um i i work in agriculture so i
got plenty of plenty of work um i picked
up a a second job
um so i'm scraping you know it's minimum
wage but you know i'm just great doing
as much as i can to bring we want to
give to you something you're asking
about resources i'm going to gift you
financial peace university and i want
you to sit down with your wife watch all
nine video lessons and with that it'll
come with every dollar our premium
version to connect with your bank and
start your budget and that's all
included in ramsey plus so hang on the
line austin will uh make sure we get
that taken care of and over to you but
man you got to get real serious about
this we got to stop playing around with
crypto and stocks and i mean you touch
the hot stove now and so you know
um that that was a bad move so i feel
good about that part ken that the
behavior changes he's ready for it yeah
and and matthew welcome because you're
joining throngs of people that have made
bad financial decisions and i i think
the word i want to share with you as we
let you go is i don't want you to have
any shame
um
the bad news is you made some some bad
financial decisions the good news is
there is a plan there's a way we're
giving it to you financial peace and
you're going to climb out of this and
you're going to be better for it so get
your head up
you'll get out of this
but you're going to have to really
really hustle for a season but on the
other side of this is going to be true
freedom